hey you guys here we are again for
another flickers of fear and it's still
folk horror february so today we are
talking about a classic from the 1960s
and this is one of the ones that i had
that i really wanted to do this month
because this was actually a movie that i
had heard a lot about particularly in
regards to folklore it's one that comes
up a lot when you're talking about it
and it was one that i had never seen
before so i went ahead and put it on the
docket not realizing that it was three
hours long
so when i actually went to watch it i
said oh you know i have a couple of
hours uh you know i'm gonna watch that
movie and then i can record a review of
it and i was like oh no it's three hours
so i actually had to kind of watch it in
uh two sittings now interestingly when
they released this film which is called
qui-don by the way
in the united states they actually cut
it almost in half by taking out one of
the segments so i'll get into that uh in
a little bit
so this movie quaidon
which
roughly just means ghost stories
is uh came out in 1965 uh from touhou
studios uh directed by masaki kobayashi
now this
is actually an anthology of ghost
stories there are four stories in there
and all of them well almost all of them
are adapted from uh kind of just
folklore type stories that were
collected um in the books of a dude
named lafkadio hearn now he was a guy i
think he was born in greece uh so i
think he was like half greek half
british but later on he actually moved
to japan i believe and like uh married a
japanese woman and was one of the people
that was very instrumental in bringing
japanese folklore translating a lot of
japanese ghost stories and folklore and
stuff for a western audience
so
that's what uh most of these stories are
from he wrote a book that came out in
1904 which was called qui-dan
stories and studies of strange things
and i believe three of the stories two
or three of the stories uh in the movie
are from that and then there's another
story called uh the reconciliation which
came from another one of his books
called shadowings that came out in 1800
and that was adapted for this story as
well now as i said this movie is uh
quite long when this was released in the
united states in the 60s they actually
cut out the entire second segment making
the movie a little over an hour and a
half
but uh if you're gonna go all in for the
experience which you totally should um
then i would recommend you know getting
the blu-ray i believe the dvd only has
the shortened version i could be wrong
about that but uh they have a criterion
collection
because as i said this is considered a
classic of japanese cinema and of folk
horror uh but yeah if you're gonna if
you're gonna go all in for it you might
as well go all in and to be honest the
the shortened version
in my opinion i think they took out the
best segment which i thought was really
dumb but okay you know it's one of those
things it's like why can you really like
question that decision i i don't know uh
but yeah so this movie uh it actually
got very good um as i said it's a
classic it got really good uh reviews
when it came out i believe it also got a
an academy award nomination uh the year
came out for best
foreign language film
so this is
broken into four stories which are
unrelated uh they're all set during
different historical time periods and as
i said they're basically all folklore
fairy tales they're all uh ghost stories
a couple of them will probably seem very
familiar uh to people who you know know
a lot about asian horror or even some of
the stories have been adapted in uh
western cinema as well so these are like
pretty pretty common uh ghost stories
particularly nowadays when so many
people are into japanese films and manga
and stuff like that
so a lot of these stories may seem
familiar to you
so the first story that you have is
actually called the black hair and this
was the one that was adapted from the
story called uh the reconciliation
so what happens in this one
is that uh there's a guy who uh he's
like a swordsman samurai type guy
and he lives with his wife who is a
weaver and they live in kyoto and
they're uh actually quite poor
and so the guy decides i'm not having
any more of this poverty [ __ ] which
you know i feel that i get it um you
know what i mean uh so he says to his
wife uh you know you're a good wife and
everything but i don't really like this
poor [ __ ] anymore so he kind of gets
this offer to go work for this and go
marry this kind of like noble woman
so he divorces his first wife and uh
takes off to marry the second one uh
just to get her money
now not too long after this whole
situation comes to pass
he figures out wow like this new wife of
mine is really
kind of not all that great she's very
selfish she's you know she's she's kind
of a [ __ ] to be honest with you
and he's like really not into it
and then uh he starts to feel bad uh
rightfully so i should add
about the poor uh dutiful wife that he
left behind uh who just spent all day
weaving and was you know
you know just
always
nice to him and [ __ ] like that she's
like he's like man why why did i just
like leave that awesome wife back in
kyoto and he starts feeling really bad
but uh he still lets quite a bit of time
go by i don't think they say
specifically how long it is but they do
kind of say like oh years go by or
whatever
so finally uh he gets it together and he
tells the second wife you know look i
you know i feel bad about leaving my
first wife i basically just married you
for the money or what i mean you know
she kind of knew that anyway and uh he's
like so i'm just gonna i'm out of here
i'm going back home
so he goes back home and interestingly
when he gets back to his house in kyoto
it looks kind of like
a a little bit like abandoned out front
like no one's done any yard work or
nothing like that but when he goes in
there his wife is still in there just
weaving on her loom like always and she
looks pretty much exactly the same even
though it's been several years since the
guy left
he thinks this is a little strange but
not strange enough to be like uh oh
supernatural shit's a foot or anything
like that
so he comes back
and he apologizes profusely and he was
just like look i just did it for the
money and it's like then i realized i
missed you and you know it was all this
other stuff so she instead of being like
super pissed off at him it's just kind
of like oh you know don't feel bad on my
account i always felt like i wasn't a
worthy wife to you and all this other
stuff and you know now we can have all
this time together or she says something
kind of um
a little bit strange like oh we can we
just have this moment together or we can
live a whole lifetime in this moment or
something like that and he doesn't
really think anything too much about
that and he's just kind of like okay
awesome so they spend this one last
night together but then when he wakes up
the next day he finds that the wife is
actually
long dead she's pretty much mummified
skeletonized the whole deal
so it was just kind of like an illusion
that um that he saw her the way she was
when he came back so she's been like
dead the whole time and not only that
but not only is his wife dead but then
he also
starts aging really quickly so he
basically just like ages over the course
of like one day oh and also his wife's
black hair
is attacking him so there's that um
which i will say this this is a
beautiful looking movie like i said this
it's from the 1960s 1965 this came out
um but that's kind of the one like
special effect that i will ding it for
is like there's one point where
the black hair like attacks the guy and
you can see that it's just like very
obviously just like a black wig on a
string
but it was just like a really like quick
thing so it didn't bother me that much
but i did seem like oh it's awesome you
know what i mean but uh but yeah so that
was uh that whole story
and then the second one
the second story uh is actually called
the woman of the snow now to me
i think this is the best one
and weirdly as i said earlier when they
released this in the u.s this was the
segment that they took out even though i
think this was the best one but you know
go figure so yeah so the woman of the
snow she's a yukiana which i guess is
that's a yokai so it's kind of like
you know it's like i said it's a
folklore uh type of uh female spirit
so you have these two guys and they're
out uh doing what they're doing i think
they're cutting wood or something and
they get stuck out in this blizzard
and so they're trying to like you know
the snow is blowing everywhere so they
go and hide in this hut
and while they're in there the older guy
the older woodcutter
uh he gets killed or dies because um the
woman of the snow the yukiana comes and
like breathes on him and like frosts him
and he dies
and she's gonna kill the other one too
uh whose name is uh minokichi
but then she says no you're pretty young
and you're kinda handsome so i'm gonna
let you live but
don't ever ever tell anybody about any
of this [ __ ] or i'm gonna come back and
kill you so he's like okay i can do
now not too long after this experience
uh he's traveling somewhere along the
road and he meets a young woman who is
on her name on her way to uh ido
now her name is yuki and you would think
that he would i mean i think a couple of
years had passed at this point because i
think later on they established that
he'd kind of like forgotten not
forgotten about the weird woman of the
snow thing but
enough that he didn't really like
remember
so i'm sure it will surprise no one to
know that this woman uh is the woman of
the snow but she looks like normal
so
they meet uh he's like hey why don't you
come back to my mom's house like we'll
make you some food and then we'll you
know get you back on your way or
whatever but then they end up falling in
love they get married they have three
kids and everything is wonderful and
happy and they're super delighted with
one another so they're married for 10
years
several other women in the village are
kind of always i don't want to say catty
necessarily but they're always kind of
saying man yuki always looks so young
even though she's had three kids how the
hell do you think she manages that you
know you know pilates i don't know but
yeah so
they're all kind of like they're all
catty about the fact that she looks
really young spoiler alert like i said
it's because she's [ __ ] supernatural
but nobody seems to twig onto that fact
so uh so as i said they're very very
happy for 10 years but then
uh one night comes when
uh mino kichi is making sandals uh new
sandals cause it's new years uh making
new sandals for the kids and making new
sandals for his wife
and
while she's uh she's making like a new
kimono and while she's over there like
sewing or whatever he looks at her and
he says gosh you know
in that light you looked just like this
woman that i met like 10 years ago and
then you're like uh oh don't do it don't
do it and then he tells her
about he's like you know the damnedest
thing like 10 years ago and i'd kind of
forgotten a lot about it but you look
just like her now just then and so he
tells her the story at which point
obviously she turns back into the woman
of the snow she's like [ __ ] that
she doesn't say that but she says
[ __ ] i told you not to tell
anybody or i was gonna kill you i'm the
yukiana we everything was happy you had
to go and [ __ ] it up
but uh she does kind of go back in her
promise she's like look i would kill you
but we got these kids here
so i'm not gonna um because you know i
presumably shouldn't want to leave the
kids orphans so she said but if i ever
hear that you are not taking good care
of these kids i'm gonna come back and
[ __ ] you up and then she like leaves and
goes back out into the snow and fades
off into the distance and i think that
some of you and i've seen other people
mention this as well because when i was
watching it i was like hello tales from
the dark side yeah tales from the dark
side that horror anthology movie when
the [ __ ] did that come out the early 90s
i want to say it was the late 80s or
early 90s it was supposed to be creep
show three but then it goes it was a
whole thing and uh it's one of the
stories in there the one with raydon
chong in it was basically the same thing
where like a guy meets like a hot woman
and they get married and have kids and
everything and uh but it turns out she's
really a demon and she just
and you know so the demon made a deal
with him look i won't kill you if you
don't tell anybody about me and he's
like okay i can do that but then
years later like he tells his wife about
it and then she turns back into the
demon and she's just kind of like i told
you not to say anything you [ __ ] oh
sorry so it's pretty much the same story
as that
so i think honestly
uh this was my favorite of all of the
stories all of them are pretty good um
the last one is kind of a little
thin um but we'll get to that in a
second but i think this was my favorite
one so that's why i think it's like kind
of ironic that this is the one that they
chose to take out but i don't know
whatever it was a little weird so the
third one uh is actually called huichi
the earless which is a great [ __ ]
title and this one is uh by far the
longest of all of them honestly houichi
the earliest i think is
almost long enough to be a movie in its
own right i think it's like a little bit
over an hour
so this actually uh deals with a young
blind man named hoichi obviously
and he plays the uh biwa i guess is how
you pronounce it it's like a loot type
thing
and uh so he kind of goes from play he
can go from place to place and he sings
like all the these epic sagas of like
all these battles and stuff
and his specialty
is going around and chanting or singing
the uh what's called the tale of the
haiki about the battle of adeno era
which was these two clans that fought
and so you can kind of see like they
they have uh they show like these big
sea battles and it's this big epic [ __ ]
and there's like there's ritual suicide
there's a whole thing
so uh hoichi
actually kind of like sits there and
plays the biwa and you know chants like
the the story about it
so he's kind of at this uh
temple i guess he's like a temple
attendant or something
and uh so the other guys there kind of
look after him and feed him or whatever
so he's kind of out on the porch playing
his biwo one night and this guy in armor
uh sidles on up to him now he can't see
the guy
uh but the guy says hey we heard that
you were like the best biwa player
around and we heard that you could sing
this like saga so
uh my lord would like you to come and
play for him
so he's like okay i can do that so but
it's like the middle of the night
so
it turns out that uh so hoichi goes to
this place and there's this whole big
like retinue of people man it's like a
big temple and there's just like people
every you know there's just a whole
[ __ ] royal family like an emperor
kind of [ __ ] it's a whole thing so he
just sits there and he plays his b1 and
sings the whole saga
now as it turns out like i said that's
this isn't really spoiler alert because
a lot of these uh stories are pretty
commonly known and even if you're
watching them now because they've been
retold and stuff like that so many times
like it's not like any of them will be
super surprising or anything these are
all ghost stories so you can pretty much
figure out where it's going so all of
these are ghosts of people that were
actually killed in the battle you know
many hundred years ago or whatever like
that he's singing about but because he's
blind all he can he can just hear their
voices and like sense them around and
stuff but he can't see them and they
kind of look like people but um when
they show like the guy coming up to him
like at the porch and he can kind of see
through him he's a little bit
transparent
but obviously the blind guy can't see
that
so he does this a few nights uh the
ghost tells him uh you know even though
he doesn't know it's a ghost he says you
know look don't tell anybody where where
you are um so he kind of gets into an
awkward situation at the temple because
he's out all night and he's looking kind
of like sickly and everybody is asking
him it was like where are you taking off
to and now you got a girlfriend or what
the [ __ ] and uh he's like oh i just had
some stuff to do and he just like won't
tell them
but after a while uh the guy that runs
the temple figures out like what's going
on and he's like oh my god you can't
ever like do what a ghost asks you to do
because now he's gonna like suck all
your soul or whatever
and uh that's not good
so he's like so what we need to do is we
need to he's like you're gonna die if
you keep doing what this what these
ghosts want
so he's like okay well what we're gonna
do is we're gonna take you and we're
gonna paint and this is actually one of
the most iconic images from the movie i
feel like because it's even like on the
cover like so it's like hoichi um like
his face with all of these characters
like painted all over
so like okay we're gonna paint the heart
sutra and we're just going to paint it
every over every single inch of your
body and then if we do that you sit down
on the porch when the ghost comes he
won't be able to see you
and you just have to like sit there
don't be scared um you know if the ghost
talks to you don't answer him just like
sit there still and don't answer and
we'll just
keep playing it that way until the ghost
like get bored i guess and like don't
come back anymore
so uh so yeah so they do that
however uh the guy that's painting
the characters on there i mean
he really [ __ ] dropped the ball on
this she would think this is like the
first time that he painted a hard suit
on everybody so that he can't be seen by
the ghost but he [ __ ] it up
uh and i'm sure that you will probably
figure out because the name of this
story is houichi the earliest uh he
forgets to paint
the characters on huichi's ears
so when the ghost comes
he doesn't see huichi at first but then
he's kind of like looking being like
what the [ __ ] i see his biwa there and
it's like i feel like somebody's there
but i can't see anybody but then he just
sees the ears
so he's like well damn he's like well
i'm gonna pull those ears off and take
him back to my lord as proof
like i did come here and try to get the
kid he's not here but there's these ears
so i'm going to rip him off so this poor
blind kid threw no fault of his own just
because he was a good b-1 player this
ghost shows up he doesn't even know it's
a ghost because he's blind and he can't
see it and so
this poor kid gets his [ __ ] ears torn
off uh you know i i felt really bad i
felt really bad
uh so yeah he gets his aerosol and i
have to say like the dude like the guy
at the temple that like painted the
characters on him like he felt bad but i
feel like he didn't feel as bad as he
should have felt you know what i mean he
was just kind of like oh man my bad i
forgot the ears
rats i'm just like
yeah cool that's that's real cool uh so
yeah so now this kid got his ears torn
out
but i guess it all works out in the end
because uh the ghosts don't come back
after that because they think that
houichi is gone
they got his ears and they don't return
and it ends up that because of this
whole story houichi gets so famous uh
because of his uh singing of the sagas
and in particular this one battle that
he always sings about so he gets like
all these actual living people that pay
like [ __ ] tons of money to
uh to hire him to sing it for the thing
so that's the thing too is like when he
goes like when you see him go and play
for all the ghosts
that's what it looks like to us
but when other guys like go and like
pull him away they're like there's
nobody there you're in a big cemetery
and that's where all the because they
show like it's just all these
gravestones see that's like where all
the guys from that
were all the people from that battle
were
so uh so he loses his ears but he does
end up really really rich like
essentially like a rock star of the day
so i guess it all worked out okay in the
end uh you know
now the last story again this one was a
little strange because i feel like
i don't know
if this one was like actually unfinished
or if
they were just saying it was unfinished
and they're kind of like making a meta
joke about it i just i didn't really get
that so this last one which is actually
quite short
is called in a cup of tea it's almost a
little bit like a twilight zone episode
i want to say
because there's a guy it's like i said
it's a little bit meta meta it's like
there's this writer
and he's telling the story and he's just
like yeah we got this story but it's not
finished but we're gonna tell you what
we got
so he's like okay there's this dude
named uh second i
and he's going someplace and he stops to
get uh a cup of tea like in a tea house
and he looks in the t and instead of
seeing like his own reflection or
whatever he sees like this random ass
dude's reflection that's like smirking
at him really creepily and he's like
what the [ __ ] is that all about and uh
which is weird you wouldn't think that
you would drink the tea after that but
he's just like [ __ ] it so he just like
drinks the tea anyway
now
at this point like so he gets another
cup of tea later and sees the same
random ass dude in there and at this
point the guy says uh his name is um
hainai shikibu i think is how you
pronounce it
and so second i was just like hey i just
saw this random mouse dude and he said
what his name is he was in my tea and
they're just like what the [ __ ] have her
bro okay and they don't believe him but
later on here's the weird thing later on
like that dude it does actually kind of
pop up in his house and like hey i'm a
ghost hey i'm over here and he does that
but like you know and the guys don't
believe that he saw him but then later
on like these three other dudes show up
at his house
that say oh we're attendants of this of
this guy that you saw in your tea
and he says
that you
assaulted him with your sword or
something so we are here to take revenge
on you so then they have a big sword
fight
but then that's the end you know what i
mean like i said because they said it
was unfinished
so
the author like i said the writer in the
inside the story this is getting
complicated but he says yeah well i
could have written an ending for this
but um i think i want to leave it to you
guys imagination
but then
in the same story like this publisher
comes to see the writer and then the
writer
like the writer's face is trapped inside
the t now too so you know what i'm
saying so that does actually seem like
an end even though you don't see what
happens to
second i but to send the same thing
happens to the writer so like i said i
don't know if it's actually unfinished
or they're just making a joke and it's
like meta and i'm not getting it i'm not
really sure but that last one like i
said i think is the weakest one and it's
really strange that they kind of um that
they put it at the end like that
particularly after houichi the earliest
which like i said was very very long
which was you know more than an hour
long and then you have this last one
which is like 10 minutes or something
like 10 or 15 minutes i just thought
that was really bizarre i think they did
kind of structure it
that each story was supposed to
represent a dis different season
which
you can't it's not super obvious i guess
like woman of the snow is obviously like
a wintertime one but
i didn't really get the sense that each
one was supposed to be a different
season but that's kind of like what i uh
gleaned from like reading about it
so now this movie as i said um it's
quite long it's more than three hours i
think three hours and three minutes
something like that uh if you get the
the complete version and i will say that
this is a movie that you definitely have
to
commit to because not only is it very
long but it is very very
very
slow
i mean it's
the whole like um structure of it is
very much like a very very deliberate
um it's almost kind of like because all
of it is filmed on sound stages and
there is no
um there's really no effort made to
disguise that fact they want it to look
artificial
and in that way i actually really like
the look of this because it's almost
like you're going to see like a big
elaborate stage play and they do some
really cool [ __ ] with it like i said
women of the snow where they have this
whole like snowy
forest like on a sound stage and then
they have these crazy like painted
backdrops in the back that are all these
crazy colors and like it looks like all
these swirling clouds but they all look
like eyes so like all these like eyes
are looking at you like from the sky and
then later on like when it's kind of
like in that same story when it's kind
of like summer the um the sky in the
background is all these like red swirls
and it looks really cool but like i said
it's not
it's not trying to look realistic it's
trying to look you know it's it's very
much like reveling in its artifice um
during the huichi the earless segment
there's also like a big sea battle
but it's staged the way that you would
see a big sea battle staged like i said
maybe like in an opera or something like
that it's very elaborate but they're not
trying to hide that it's artificial
they're just kind of like leaning into
the artifice and i think that was
actually a really good idea because it
gives this a very
otherworldly kind of vibe to it because
you can tell it's not real you know it's
set during historical time periods
they're all based on folklore and fairy
tales so they're not really trying to be
realistic in any sense of the word so it
is like very fantasy based and the
cinematography is really really
beautiful the sound design is great it
doesn't really even have
i don't want to say it doesn't have a
score um because it does in parts
but
it it's it makes like really great
creepy like unsettling use of like
strange like incidental sounds you know
what i mean kind of like like tapping
and knocking and
things like that and uh it makes a lot
of use of silence as well um which you
know if you've seen it you kind of know
what i'm talking about but it's just
it's very spare
and really the whole thing is kind of
like that so as i said just keep in mind
that
this is very
very
deliberately paced i saw like another
reviewer that said it was stately i was
like that's yeah that's a good word for
it um if you're not in the mood for it
then you might just be like what the
[ __ ] like everything is taking forever
like to happen which i get that but if
you're kind of just willing to
let it
uh let it sit with you let it kind of do
its thing
then there's something kind of like
hypnotic about it like in a really weird
sort of way as i said some of the
stories are stronger than the others
woman in the snow is probably my
favorite one um and really i think the
only weak one is the last one just
because it's so short and it seems kind
of like is that it particularly because
it was the last one you'd think they'd
kind of maybe want to go out with a bang
or whatever and uh it just seemed like a
strange choice to like kind of just tack
this short one on the end particularly
after you know the hoichi the earliest
segment which was really really long and
very involved and almost kind of like a
movie on its own so the last segment
just seems like a little bit of an
afterthought and i do kind of wish that
maybe it had been fleshed out a little
bit more but on the whole
i mean if you like japanese cinema and
you're kind of willing to
meet the movie
halfway um you know and if you're
willing to like make the commitment to
it i mean it's beautiful to look at um
the acting is amazing it does actually
have some really creepy
uh imagery and just like some i just
really like the whole like vibe of it i
guess
um but you know like i said keep in mind
it is very very very very very
very slow and that's like say that's a
lot like coming from me because i don't
mind that at all but even me
like a couple times i gotta say like a
couple times i was like this is starting
to try my patients a little bit but
if you stick with it it's it's just like
a whole
experience like i said it's almost kind
of like sitting through an opera
a little bit um so yeah uh if that
sounds like something you did and you
know tell me if you guys have seen it
because i know this is a classic i had
never seen it and i really felt like
well i really need to get around to
watching this because i feel like this
is one that a lot of people
bring up and i feel like uh when i was
thinking about doing folk horror
february i said well at least want to do
some
uh you know at least one asian
uh cinema
you know uh pick and i picked this one
specifically because i had not seen it
and i wanted to rectify that so i'm
actually glad i have seen it now
so if you guys have seen it let me know
what you thought about it in the
comments uh if you'd like to watch it i
actually just rented it on amazon prime
i think it was just 3.99 or something
like that like i said it's three hours
so set uh set aside a good chunk of time
to watch it if you're going to because i
didn't realize it was that long when i
first started watching it so i had to
kind of break it up into two chunks
because i didn't have time to like watch
it all at once but uh you know it was
definitely worth watching and it's
definitely an experience so let me know
what you thought about in the comments
if you've seen it and uh i will be back
on another one uh we're still doing folk
horror february we got a couple more of
those to go uh so yeah i will see you
guys again on the next one
bye